[Applaudissements]
voilà attention les mains bas les pattes
asticots on trouve à l'est c'est ta
chronique kg match du week-end aux
sports elle nous vient d'argentine ou un
gars de tentes de volley en salle en
conférence de presse les entraîneurs ils
ont une tablette devant eux avec un
petit peu là la formation qu'ils ont
fait tout ce qu'ils doivent dire bah ya
un gars qui sait y tiens je vais voler
la tablette de l'entraîneur à la fin de
la course de presse mais réalise trop
tard qu'il est filmé a apparemment une
intervention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
il
[Musique]
la série la série 3 de plus en plus de
temps je l'avais dit juste à tourbes et
rappelé je pense que c'était sa dernière
ce soir patrick la nostalgie on
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
n'atteindra qu'un cas dans un instant
pour lui faire gagner un voyage qu'a
fait patrick aujourd'hui pour le pic
d'audience à 20h46 merci mais rigide à
petits pas de danse à ya quand même y'a
quand même un mec qui est encore en
aventurier autour de la table et
personne ne dit rien mais parle de votre
lampe à ce que ça change supporter tu es
chaud au plus bas comme merci merci
beaucoup allez on y va à boca vie va
falloir refaire tout le monde s'en va